qui aurait cru qu'un jour l'éléphant
serait une espèce en voie de disparition
et ce n'est pas le seul animal les
tigres les chimpanzés les rhinocéros et
d'autres animaux vertébrés verrait leurs
jours comptés le rapport du fonds
mondial pour la nature et sans équivoque
en 44 ans les populations d'animaux
vertébrés ont chuté de plus de la moitié
l'être humain aura-t-il eu raison de la
planète à son propre détriment depuis
1970 60% des vertébrés sauvages ont
disparu et ce n'est pas mieux dans le
monde marin 60 % des poissons reptiles
oiseaux manchots ont également disparu
et ceux qui survivent sont dans un
piteux état
90% des oiseaux marins ont du plastique
dans l'estomac et ce tissu vivant on
voit année après année qu'il est en
train de s'effilocher se désagréger la
cause de 1 pour des causes que l'on
connaît assez bien la destruction des
habitats la surexploitation des espèces
la pollution l'introduction de nouvelles
espèces d'un continent à l'autre le
réchauffement du climat maintenant
et donc on veut tout ce qui est en train
de se dégrader sous nos yeux
cette vidéo devenue virale traduit bien
le drame des bêtes un orang outan qui se
bat désespérément contre un bulldozer
pour protéger son habitat naturel
quant aux éléphants 20 à 30000
disparaissent chaque année à cause du
braconnage pour le trafic de l'ivoire la
perte de biodiversité de populations
sauvages menace l'écosystème de la
planète la planète doit être sous
respirateur artificiel y est le
directeur du fonds mondial pour la
nature
la population a le choix agir ou laisser
la planète se dégrade
les chiffres sont encore plus alarmants
en amérique latine on parle d'une perte
de 89 % de leur faune sauvage
[Applaudissements]
l'élection de gerbes aux sonars au
brésil n'arrangerait pas les choses car
il rendrait plus facile l'approbation
des projets minière en amazonie menaçant
ainsi toute la faune sur les gens
d'affaires doivent prendre leur
responsabilité d'i télé chaque individu
doit se battre pour la planète
mais quelques signes d'espoir comme ici
un orphelinat d'éléphants au kenya mais
pour beaucoup l'heure n'est plus à la
discussion ni au débat il faut agir car
la sixième extinction massive est bel et
bien en marche
ici à la bodega qui sera du canada
montréal